edie Bichette covers the Steelers for
the athletic and he's been on the
Steelers beat since 1985 good morning ed
how are you I'm great dan thank you if
we just asked this question if I gave
the Raiders a mulligan on Antonio Brown
trade would they still take Antonio
Brown well they didn't give up that much
I would think yes they would the helmet
thing is behind them it seems like the
fetal heel so he'll go into this season
he doesn't need training camp anyway I
mean maybe he needed to learn their
offense a little bit but yeah I think
they still would have if I gave the
Steelers a mulligan on trading Antonio
Brown well I wrote before they made the
trade that they should do it even if
they get a bag of footballs that aren't
inflated Dan they they needed to get rid
of him it just it was a marriage that
was breaking apart and well what if you
know and was there a moment that
something specific or you know sometimes
you become the underdog story and then
you're the favorite and then you become
something different than what people
thought you were something changed last
year Dan and I don't know what it was I
mean his whole demeanor from the spring
and did a training camp and you know a
lot of people didn't see it we saw saw
it and it started coming out about the
furniture the ticket going over a
hundred miles an hour on a road in
Pittsburgh some of the other stuff and
it just it was like a volcano that's
finally erupted in that last week is
there any chance this year's Steelers
are better than last year Steelers oh I
think they will be din that let's not
look at the offenses their defense is
going to be a lot better I think they
finally found an inside linebacker
actually they found too they signed Marc
Baron from the Rams and they signed
Devon Bush and that that improves them
greatly already at inside linebacker
they've had a couple young kids or who
are
going to grow on that defense and be
better now injuries can throw everything
off you know with any team but yeah
they're gonna be faster you know what
they led the league in sacks in each of
the last two years they don't give up a
lot of yards the problem last season
specifically was they didn't didn't come
up they didn't produce turnovers they're
eight interceptions was a franchise low
so you have to figure they're going to
come up with more than eight this year
and your pass rush should be maybe even
better what did you think of Ben
Roethlisberger's saying apologizing for
maybe ruining a friendship with Antonio
Brown yeah I don't know how close a
friendship that really was it was more
professional I think then and I think he
was just trying to put it be put
everything behind him you know trying to
you know throw throw Antoniou bone there
and saying hey you know I didn't you
know I'm sorry I said it
and then it came back to bite him when
when a Antonio responds but you know
been blamed Antonio browner publicly
called him out and when did when did
that relationship start to fracture um
last season I think Dan I mean it like I
said it was never friendship if you will
it was more professional and and the two
were on the same page professionally he
called him out that's a little strong he
said something on a radio show that he
told Antonia we should have run a flat
route there in the end zone in Denver
and gee tom brady's never said anything
like that or other quarterbacks have
never said anything like that right yeah
but he threw it to a defensive lineman
you know so I mean you can blame Antonio
Brown but I don't know it just felt like
Ben was not taking the heat and he kind
of pushed it off to Antonio Brown that
was my take from from that Ed but Dan if
you've been around him he takes the heat
a lot he takes responsibility okay a lot
and so he gets a pass there because he's
always been honest on those kinds of
things
aren't you bummed out though you don't
have antonio brown to cover anymore not
at all no no he gave you a concept he
talked once a week on Fridays my day off
was on Fridays never dealt with him
verbally accosted me in training camp
for whatever reason I have no idea no
I'm glad to see him going
were you nervous were you when he
verbally accosted you I wasn't nervous I
was surprised I was talking with Marcus
Gilbert the big tackle the Steelers had
about his newborn and Antonio didn't
like something I tweeted that he had you
know left practice and turns out Mike
Talman allowed him to leave practice and
I corrected that but he didn't like that
and he came over and started calling me
names if if it goes south this year who
gets blamed everybody they'll get it you
know if they don't make the playoffs
again and if it really goes south they
Dave table you know Kevin Kolbert the GM
like Tom and certainly Ben if he doesn't
perform up to levels ownership the
expectations here are still very high
dan thank you ad great to talk to you as
always all right thanks for having me on
again Dan I'll see you later and that's
ed Bhushan he covers the Steelers for
the athletic he's been on that beat
since 1985 for more Dan Patrick show
tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]